hi elena so what's the problem this time  i got a big big problem doctor you know  i'm completely addicted to this  fantastic website even carmichael.com  and  now it's just a drug to me you know at  the beginning i used to visit it  two or three times a day but now doctor  i visited all day long i really can't go  home like this doctor really  i see but don't worry that's simply  great everybody loves it  yeah yeah it's great i know isn't it but  doctor really you gotta help me  somewhere because i can't go home like  this i'm always on this website and i  haven't live anymore  help me please  don't worry and i give you my suggestion  keep using it all the time and just  enjoy it  yeah  yeah maybe you're right doctor i mean if  you like it too  it can be the bed right  yeah doctor you save me as always  yeah i will go home and i will go to  evencarmichael.com  and you all should check it out because  evencarmichael.com is simply amazing